vous avez été nombreux cet après midi à
suivre à réagir et à débattre au débat
qui est encore en cours au sénat et qui
était retransmis sur figaro live il
s'agit de débattre d'une proposition de
loi portée par la sénatrice du val
d'oise brigitte eustache brinio pour
autant l'opportunité de ce débat a été
remise en cause par une autre sénatrice
la socialiste est élu d'une bouches du
rhône samia gagne les enfants sorties
scolaires
elles font quoi de mal que d'accompagner
et de permettre justement à des enfants
de pouvoir découvrir des d'aller au
cinéma dès le théâtre d'aller dans des
musées parce que c'est ça et ça que j'ai
demandé à monsieur de retailleau de
retirer cette proposition de loi qui
n'amène à rien mais à part un débat
stérile un débat haineux et qui de mon
point de vue n'a pas avancé
les valeurs de la république bien au
contraire l effet reculé et cet après
midi samia ghali a réitéré ses propos
cette fois ci dans l'hémicycle du sénat
hervé nathan il fallait pas débattre je
vous dis un mot d'abord fait rendre
hommage aux deux septuagénaires qu'on
est extrêmement courageux parce qu'ils
se sont portés au devant leurs
agresseurs à bayonne parce que on est
dans un climat peu après la
représentation nationale avoir discuté
de ce qu'elle veut fixe son ordre du
jour avec le gouvernement d'ailleurs en
général
et là il se trouve que si on en débat
maintenance et puis c'est passé quelque
chose dans les heures qui vit qui nous
ont précédés ce qui nous a précédés
c'est un attentat contre une mosquée à
bayonne il ya deux septuagénaires ont
largement passé sous les 70 ans qui sont
à l'hôpital avec une balle avec des
balles dans le corps
et donc je veux rendre hommage à leur
courage parce qu'ils se sont
courageusement opposé à l'agresseur
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont et celle des
agresseurs leur a tiré dessus parce
qu'ils s'opposaient à eux ils essayent
de maîtriser ont fait suffisamment
damage aux forces de police quand est ce
quand elles se portent courageusement
défendu citoyens me colle ses citoyens
au même jeu insiste sur le mot citoyen
puisque ce nom nos concitoyens qui se
reposait un acte pour moi terroristes on
en discutera sûrement voilà donc c'est
pour moi c'est très important de dire ça
parce qu'il ne comprend pas bien mais en
allant oui moi je pense que dans ces
circonstances là on aurait pu repousser
ces propositions loi toute façon ce
problème
ça fait des années qu'on traîne on
pourrait être ce n'est qu'une
proposition de loi de toute façon
l'assemblée nationale il ya toutes les
chances que cette loi ne passe pas parce
que l'eau potable la majorité est plutôt
contre la république en marche
voilà donc on pouvait leur poser voilà
voilà voilà
mais c'est moi voilà maintenant je pense
que oui donc par les sens peut-être
parce qu'il ya un épisode très important
que s'est passé on pouvait le report
leur porte et j'ai pas diminuer leur
portée non moi je crois pas je pense
qu'il faut toujours parler des choses
c'est que c'est pas parce qu'on parle
pas des choses qu'on les règle
au contraire si on veut régler les
problèmes il faut en parler et c'est pas
parce qu'on parle des choses qu'on crée
des problèmes et c'est au bras parce
qu'on n'en parle pas qu'on le laisse se
développer
c'est vrai qu'on est face à une sorte de
cercle vicieux de d'affirmation d'un
islam politique de radicalisation qui
par contrecoup va entraîner c'est
évidemment pas pour le justifier une
radicalisation inverse de personnes
racistes et haineuses qui par contrecoup
var renforcés
l'affirmation d'un islam politique
radicale serait donc on a cependant ce
système qui se remplit et donc il ya
deux façons de se dire se dire bon bah
pour que ce cercle vicieux arrête de
sanctionner on n'en parle pas et je
crois pas que ces relations je pense que
pour que ces mesures est de fondre mais
il faut s'attaquer à la racine du
problème tout en dénonçant à la fois
l'islam politique et les comportements
des indications et les comportements de
haine et de racisme
qui sont absolument ignobles et je pense
que c'est aussi absurde de dire il ne
faut pas critiquer l'islam isme parce
que ça crée du racisme que dire il ne
faut pas créer du racisme parce que ça
que ça ça il faut pas critiquer nos
racines de ce que ça crée de l'islamisme
il faut d'abord critiqué et ensuite
surtout il faut prendre à bras le corps
ces problèmes de radicalisation et les
problèmes qui se posent et des factures
le voile est un vrai moi je comprends
que samia ghali
j'ai pas dit que fait l'europe mais
reporter samia ghali elle et elle contre
le fait qu'on compte qu on interdise le
port du voile dans les sorties scolaires
elle a parfaitement le droit de le
penser mais elle n'est pas contre le
fait qu enfin le fait qu'elle dise
maintenant ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
qu'il fallait en parler mais l'epa pour
en parler aujourd'hui ni demain ni après
demain elle est contre le principe donc
bon c'est une position mais je pense que
la position inverse veut absolument être
tenus en l'occurrence je crois même
qu'elles devraient être soutenus rachel
bien je fait réagir mais il ya eu une
déclaration qui étaient importantes
qu'on attendait tous également au sénat
c'était ce qui allait dire jean michel
blanquer puisque c'est leur présente
c'était le représentant du gouvernement
et donc qui a été qu un personnage
central de dents dans ces discussions
autour du voile voici ce qu'il a dit
voici comment il a vu les choses comment
il voit les choses
je vous le dis d'emblée ma position n'a
pas changé
je pensais d'ailleurs que nous en
resterons là et je regrette d'avoir
aujourd'hui à revenir sur tout cela et
il est ajouté jean michel blanquer rc
que il a dit qu' il a répété son
hostilité au port du voile mais il n'est
pas favorable à la loi ce qu'il a raison
il hyper favorable à l'interdiction de
propositions bon c'est ça pour les
sorties scolaires dans les sorties
scolaires
là où je le rejoins c'est que en effet
l'interdiction ne gomme pas le problème
de fond de problème majeur en fait que
rencontre notre pays c'est à dire que
interdire ne va pas faire mon humble
avis baisser le nombre de femmes dans
l'espace public qui porte le foulard
néanmoins ce projet doit me paraît quand
même intéressant et peut permettre de
rassurer un certain nombre de français
sur la représentation politique et
symbolique qu'a le foulard qu'on le
veuille ou non que ces femmes le veuille
ou non dans l'espace public
et je peux comprendre aussi les parents
qui ont envie que l'école reste en
sanctuaire l'école c'est aussi belle et
sorties scolaires ça s'arrête pas
uniquement à l'enceinte de
l'établissement et qui pour un certain
nombre ne souhaitent pas que leurs
enfants soient confrontés à des mères
qui porte le foulard et dans certains
territoires il faut le dire qu'ils
peuvent être majoritaire on sait que
dans un certain nombre de territoires et
de ville eh ben ce sont majoritairement
des femmes voilées qui vont ou qui
accompagnent les enfants en sortie
scolaire
donc ça pose la caisse a posé beaucoup
de questions de la symbolique même du
voile qui encore une fois n'est pas
celle qui le porte à l'idée n'est pas de
sonder les âmes pour savoir si elles ont
des motifs ou pas politique
c'est même pas c'est même pas une
question intéressante en fait et
pertinente en l'espèce philip earl vous
me confirmer c'est pas un débat qu'on
veut rendre en montagne
non non non on va voir ce genre de débat
en bretagne me je pense dans beaucoup
d'autres pays en europe justement jean
michel blanquer
est revenu cette différence et il a
affirmé que la chance de la france et
d'avoir la laïcité est selon lui à
l'étranger ils sont nombreux
peut-être pas nous envier laïcité mais à
voir les limites du multiculturalisme
partager stick
ça ouvre un autre débat j'aimerais bien
au bond et elles seront toutefois je
suis avant d aller mais la première
c'est que avant d'entendre jean michel
blin que bloquer cet après midi j'étais
plutôt de votre avis qu'il fallait
peut-être décalé ce débat parce qu'on
est à chaud après les événements de
bayonne hier mais écouter ce qu'il a dit
cet après midi au sénat
je trouve qu'il est qu'il était très
juste en ce qu'il disait
papaux au fait qu' on peut pas interdire
le port du voile pour ces femmes qui
sont sol et les voyages scolaires parce
que c'est pas des ajoncs des temps c'est
des maires des élèves qui monte dans les
camps où s'arrête une chose où commence
l'autre et si on fasse une loi saison
passée noah c'est une peste sparadrap
sur mon timbre dévoile on a fait quelque
chose mais le problème de fond n'est
absolument pas réglé donc arrêtons de
dire chaque fois qu'on a un problème et
tient à va passer une loi comme ça ça va
être réglé c'est faux donc ça c'est un
premier point deuxième chose j'ai envie
de dire mais foutez la paix à ces femmes
qui portent ces voiles c'est par eux
c'est pas elle le problème il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin pourquoi en interdit
pensez-y même ça fait des années qu'on
parle enfin des imams qui prêchent le
salafisme dans les dents les dans les
mosquées en france
même celui qui a un doctrine et le
policier qui a tiré à l'hôtel de ville
un gone ici par écrit toujours là
pourquoi on n'a pas arrêté pourquoi on
n'a pas fermé pourquoi n'avoir pas fait
quelque chose c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut attaquer en premier parce que ça
fait tâche d'huile par 6ap tache d huile
par là ça commence à prendre du terrain
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon d'y pas
tiens c'est ces femmes là on veut pas
qu'elle vienne sont renvoyés scolaire on
va interdire le voile mais ça ne règle
rien dans ce problème
et dernière chose joseph beaucoup dans
les pays scandinaves danemark en suède
mais on est grand ce qui se passe on
frontières on hallucine
mais on parle des choses mais chez nous
ça n'a même pas de conséquences on
laisse libre les jours ne fait ce qu'ils
veulent mais je ne dis pas qu'il ya pas
de problème c'est autre chose il ya eu
des problèmes il ya des problèmes comme
comment comme on a en france au danemark
ce n'est en rien oui il ya eu de
problème là bas mais ils n'ont pas la
vision française la laïcité c'est une
autre mentalité
je ne dis pas que c'est mieux ou c'est
pas bien mais je pense que le problème
n'est pas là le problème est ailleurs
juste sur ce sur ce plan là hervé jeu
rebondit ce que vous disiez il ya quand
même une majorité de français ce que
montre le sondage publié par le journal
du dimanche qui est favorable à
notamment à une interdiction du port du
voile dissimulant scolaire je me suis
vite en opportunité et un attentat ya
moi je trouve
je le dis parce qu'on veut ce débat
effectivement ce n'est pas au menu de
même je suis avec moi personnellement
choqué que le parquet antiterroriste ne
soit pas saisie de cette affaire
je trouve anormal qu'on traite ça comme
une affaire de droit commun pour le
moment une mosquée attaquée de blesser
quelqu'un qui a une extrême droite qui a
une idéologie qui professent la haine
etc
c'est là que ce concert je vais même pas
et c est bien ce serait un attentat d'un
musulman sur quelconque monuments
publics le parquet dentisterie serait
saisi il ya les éléments en tout cas y'a
vérifier s'il ya pas du terrorisme natsu
ya vrai vérifier s'il n'y a pas un
réseau avait avec alors que par exemple
on sait toujours pas si un réseau dans
la sphère de la préfecture de police
on sait toujours pas si un réseau le
fait est là pour le moment le criminel
il a l'air d'être toujours le sol et
c'est un terroriste donc ça sur balles
c'est symbolique non mais je dis voilà
pourquoi une opportunité je pense qu' il
fallait que le parti n a certes ralenti
et théories jeu j'ai sur le fond moi je
suis moi je vous partage assez l'opinion
monsieur blanc caire je sais pas j'ai
pas de débat là dessus sur ça pour ça je
pourrais je pensais que ça pouvait être
reportée parce que la position de la
guerre c'est qu'il parle il n'y a pas à
faire de loi d'une certaine manière elle
et c'est là c'est ce qui vous plaît
notre opposition les lois et d'abord il
ya des lois qui existent et il ya donc
c'est pas avec une loi qu'on va résoudre
ce problème
on aimerait que rien on est reparti
après une loi devrait absolument
interdire with accompagnatrice et bien
moi je me souviens comme je l'époque
on parle de la voie de la loi qui doit
interdire le voile à l'école et à
l'époque on dit mais c'est pas possible
ça n'arrivera pas mais puis ça va être
pire que le mal ça ne réglera rien avec
moteur de création
le résultat c'est qu'aujourd'hui ça la
question ne se pose plus donc ça prouve
quand même que noah peut avoir un effet
pas un effet sur les causes méfaits sur
les conséquences c'est déjà pas si mal
après c'est sûr que ça règlerait pas
tout mais n'empêche que ça on aurait pu
on aurait pu le faire
ça aurait au moins le mérite de ne pas
laisser seuls les chefs d'établissement
parce qu'aujourd'hui et camille
gigantesque l'hypocrisie c'est qu'on dit
dans tel établissement va l'autorisé
dans telle autre on va pas l'utiliser
ils sont là se gratter la tête
qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce que je
vais pas les causes multiples et quand
ils refusent
quand un chef d'établissement refuse il
a évidemment contre lui son nombre
d'associations parce que derrière tout
ça il ya aussi des institutions se sont
pas c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
mères de famille tout dans ma les états
mais le problème c'est que maintenant
que cette affaire est devenue politique
c'est devenu un élément pour tester la
réaction des pouvoirs publics et donc il
ya des violations et quand aujourd'hui
un chef d'établissement dit je ne veux
pas aussitôt les sessions se met en
branle et disent pourquoi tu fais pas ça
c'est l'islamophobie et cédrid cédera
donc la loi ou le fait qu'on dit
maintenant c'est fini il ya plus de voix
oui où il ya plus de maisons noah moi je
suis je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux que
je n'ai pas le droit mais mais au moins
que ce soit clair aujourd'hui on peut
tout dire sauf que c'est clair bien sûr
qu'il fallait maintenir ce débat c'est
pas parce que le contexte est tendu
qu'il faut arrêter discuter ça c'est ce
que dit nicole et à linverse macabre
nitot dudit faut être aveugle pour
croire qu'une simple loi pourrait
diminuer le radicalisme en france alors
il ya une chose qu'on n'a pas dit ce qui
quand même très important il faut le
souligner c'est que pourquoi on a eu des
attentats en france pour une raison pas
pas la seule raison mais une des raisons
c'est parce que la france est perçue
comme un pays on ti musulmane et donc si
on écoute non mais je suis désolé mais
c'est vrai ça du cette donne non mais
j'ai la haine ça donne du grain à moudre
non mais de l'extérieur par les
salafistes mais voilà encore une fois
hier
et donc on va dire ça comme ça va
réveiller
je ne dis pas qu'ils ont paru jeudi mais
ça peut réveiller plus de velléités de
ceux qui n'aiment pas la france pour
cause les attentats et autres htc
soumission c'est exactement ce message
n'est pas sûr mission g mais si on dit
qu'on n'est pas content non je suis
désolé c'est passager des lois existent
ce n'est pas la peine d'ajouter des lois
sont des lois à des lois et cetera qu'on
applique la loi qui existe de la raison
banderas sur celle sur la burqa
donc on dit ok on a juste une loi c'est
une loi qui perçu comme une oie
antimusulman ça va faire mais c'est avec
la perception et l'affect qu'on fait de
la politique
je suis contre l'idée de faire une loi
comme très bien mais vous avez dit aussi
dans la première partie de votre
intervention que quelque part il y avait
un climat pas favorable aux musulmans et
que donc il fallait pas s'étonner d'un
certain nombre d'événements qui pouvait
avoir un lien avec le sentiment qu'avait
certains musulmans à l'égard du
traitement qui leur a été fait dans
notre pays je trouve ça assez ambigu
comme position pour tout vous dire et
pas extrêmement sain je crois que la
question d'un report du débat au début
je n'ai pas compris quand on a posé la
question une vie monstres et pas de lien
entre musulmans et terrorisme donc je
vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
avoir ce débat là et puis on va pas
soumettre notre agenda notre débat
public au au terrorisme c'est pas lui
qui va nous dire ce qu'on abat n'ont pas
hélas justement là si on le fait à
chaque fois qu'un attentat excusez moi
de le dire à chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
attentats événement grave non seulement
on a tous bouleversés on a failli
changer la constitution
je rappelle pas les débats qu'on accepte
d'ailleurs sur la suppression débat sur
la laïcité
l'attentât du bataclan avec quand même
une autre ampleur
les attentats du marriott avait un autre
une autre horreur quand il attaque
contre la résolution loi mais tout
simplement une utilisation comme ça d'un
événement tragique vise pour certains je
fais pas je poste ici personne du doigt
en de manière générale à
instrumentaliser faire le procès de tout
ce qu'on aime pas et donc là c'est
l'occasion pour balayer le débat
notamment sur le port du foulard ou sur
d'autres ou sur certaines personnalités
qui auraient comme ça un lien avec
l'événement d'hier et je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire que nos adversaires
c'est dire ça d'abord vous avez l'air de
banaliser ce qui s'est passé hier à bon
signe parce que vous avez pas si vous
avez parlé d'un incident qu'un tragique
il s'agit pas d'un accident tragique il
s'agit d'un crime contre les
compatriotes pour des raisons un des
attentats contre les comploteurs contre
des compatriotes pour des raisons de
racisme c'est quand même extrêmement
grave c'est rare en france
il n'a pas beaucoup est ce que n'a pas
voulu non vous avez décrété juste
tragique
enfin oui vous allez musée à georges
wilczyk régime oui je pense que vous
aussi vous trouvez que c'est un
euphémisme que de dire que le sytral un
petit peu bon un petit peu mais surtout
de prendre cette fois pas compte que ce
que ce serait bien que ce soit
instrumentalisable écoutez moi j'ai dit
je suis en prison selon pierre monsieur
position blanc quercy vous souvenez et
puis monsieur les choses et dit je ne
crois je ne pense pas que le sait plus
que ça explique ne pas trahir son
expression il a dit que c'était pas
souhaitable si je me souviens même dans
la fuite dans la société française je
suis assez proche de ça moi ça me
dérange pas qu'on dise plus de
effectivement du goût de delap dab de
est-ce qu'on peut ou pas accompagné mais
je pense que c'est la loi n'est pas pour
être plus clair
je pense que là une législation ça pas
le meilleur moyen je vais jusqu'au bout
j'avais juste au bout ça aide
je pense que c'est un combat politique
c'est un combat politique qui est qu'une
sérieuse rappaz par les moyens
juridiques c'est un combat qui se fait
de toute la société effectivement pour
faire reculer l'islamisme comme
idéologie politique et doré et son
expression publique dans les revenants
les rues dans les rues du pays
et ça je pense que ça lui demande une
mobilisation passe mais pas des moyens
les moyens juridiques ne se n'y
arriveront pas je pense et la
mobilisation des citoyens voilà il
faudrait trouver les
et inventer peut-être quelque chose je
suis je suis d'accord que ça reste c'est
une proposition qui reste à concrétiser
mais je pense que cette voie là est la
seule qui un jour arrivera avait
considéré la société française et
extirper le l'islamisme de la scène
politique française
voilà ma voiture mais c'est une autre
proposition voilà avec si oui qu'est ce
que je voulais à propos de la question
de l'instrumentalisation
on a qu'à madrid sont donc deux
responsables associatifs nous expliquer
que les déclarations notamment de blanc
caire n'était pas directement mais
faisait partie d'un climat qui pouvait
entraîner ce genre d'acte on a quand
même entendu ça depuis depuis hier donc
ces folies ans et s'appelle de
l'instrumentalisation ça veut pas dire
que c'est moins que les faits sont moins
graves au départ mais on peut
instrumentaliser des faits gravissimes
passé plutôt ce qui était critiqué est
ailleurs jean luc mélenchon temps mais
voilà donc ça s'appelle donc donc la
question de l'instrumentalisation se
pose sans rien enlever à la gravité de
ce qui sera fait à bayonne la question
composé sur twitter aujourd'hui c'était
fait et il maintenir le débat sur le
port des signes religieux au sénat vous
avez répondu oui à 66% réaction de
vincent la religion c'est à la maison et
dans son coeur pas dans la rue ou au
boulot ou à l'école et nicole pose une
question peut-être que la fille de prof
que vous n'êtes pas pouvoir y répondre
une question un peu décalé mais à quoi
servent toutes ces sorties scolaires
l'école est faite pour son instruction
pas pour les sorties à tous ces
souvenirs qu'il y avait des sorties
scolaires
les sorties scolaires cc on parle pas de
renforcement par la tradition on parle
de sorties scolaires ou au théâtre de
l'élysée on parle de voyage de classe
vous conseillerez quantas king et
macaulay en france et me voilà je vais
en france voilà la réponse a dit que le
look apporté par exemple à philip earl
et sylvie nous dit la plupart de nos
compatriotes musulmans ne demandent qu'à
vivre leur foi
personnellement c'est un autre sujet de
débat aujourd'hui le csm qui a rappelé
que le port du voile est une
prescription religieuse à l'avis du csm
il faut le lire de près on attendait
mais mc ronde leur avaient demandé de
poser une position très ferme très
républicaine et on nous avait annoncé
une position très ferme la république
alors que des imams et on a comme
résultat le savent ce qu'ils veulent et
c'est une prescription religieuse mais
celles qui ont décidé de s'en affranchir
ne sont pas moins musulmans donc bon les
tolérer donnait pas le porter c'est
quand même intéressant comme prise de
position de et c'est assez préoccupant
me semble t'il pour un organe qui est
censé être un des organes modéré
il faut mettre en place un islam à la
française donc on n'a pas fini d'en
parler et également sa pose et peut-être
un autre sujet de débat qui est le
problème de la la voix magistérielle en
islam et en particulier dans l'islam